this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com
hey 42 here what do richard nixon jack
london david packard walter cronkite
herbert hoover michelle rocker george
bush senior and clint eastwood all have
in common are they
a all american
b
all dead or c
all one time members of a shadowy secret
society that carries out creepy and
possibly satanic rituals in the woods at
night
well let's see unless my timing with
this video is really bad then clint
eastwood should still be alive so
that's b out
and former prime minister michelle
rocker was more french than frog's legs
so a's out as well which leaves us with
c
but that obviously can't be true i mean
all those important and respected men
running around in the woods as part of
some shady illuminati-like organization
that would be insane
actually it is insane
because it's 100 percent
true
now folks if you've watched my channel
for a while you'll know i'm a huge fan
of manscapes and their new performance
package 4.0 kit which is the world's
first all-in-one men's grooming kit that
makes trimming the hedges safe
and easy but manscaped is so much more
than a ball trimmer company because
their new performance package 4.0 bundle
now includes their awesome weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer this
impressive trimmer comes with the same
proprietary skin safe technology as
their lawnmower body trimmer for you
that means less nicks snags and tugs the
manscaped weed whacker uses a powerful
9000 rpm motor with a 360 degree rotary
dual blade system
allowing you to safely whack your weeds
i should know i've worked quite a few
myself with this thing plus it's the
only nose hair trimmer on the market
with a cordless rechargeable lithium-ion
battery that lasts for up to 90 minutes
of use it really is time to upgrade your
manscaped routine with the weed whacker
nose and ear hair trimmer and the best
part is if you go to manscape.com
forward slash 42 today you'll receive 20
off and free international shipping at
checkout
that's manscape.com forward slash 42. i
think i speak for all of us when i say
thank you to manscaped for keeping our
pubes trimmed
and our noses free of weeds
every single one of the people i just
mentioned presidents actors leaders of
industry celebrated writers
was at one time or over a member of the
bohemian club perhaps the most powerful
private organization in existence and
also one of the most controversial
thanks to its reputation for doing some
shall we say
unusual things when the world is looking
the other way
the bohemian club was founded in san
francisco way back in 1872 by a group of
journalists with an interest in the arts
but over the course of its near 150 year
history the demographic of its members
has shifted dramatically the artists are
still there but these days the
journalists have mostly been replaced by
a generous helping of some of the most
influential men alive we're talking
multiple u.s presidents ceos of the
world's largest companies ivy league
university directors curators of
renowned museums
leading scientists and a whole host of
prominent politicians and policy makers
from across the globe it used to be said
that if you weren't on the waiting list
for membership by the age of 30 you'd be
dead before being accepted but it isn't
just a long list of illustrious members
that makes the bohemian club
so intriguing because
every year a couple of thousand of its
members descend on a private tract of
redwood forest in northern california
for what can best be described as a
two-week scout camp with a twist
that twist being remarkable amounts of
alcohol a series of bizarre rituals and
some of the world's most powerful men in
drag
welcome to bohemian grove
the camp kicks off every year in the
same strange and slightly terrifying
fashion
with the ritual burning of a human
sacrifice
i meant with the ritual burning of a
human effigy in sacrifice
sorry that was quite an important
difference wasn't it
this ceremony known as the cremation of
care is purely symbolic the effigy
represents the club members many cares
and responsibilities
by burning it the worries of the outside
world are banished to spice things up a
bit the whole ceremony takes place under
the watchful gaze of a towering 12 meter
owl statue the bohemian club's mascot
this giga owl takes an active part in
the ceremony too
speaking in the pre-recorded voice of
legendary news reader walter cronkite
and just in case all of that wasn't
weird enough bohemian club members who
take part in the ceremony all wear what
look like ku klux klan robes that
someone accidentally put through the
wash with a red sock it probably sounds
like i'm making all of this up but
seriously the cremation of care ceremony
happens each and every year to open the
bohemian grove camp
alex jones of infowars fame even managed
to film it once after sneaking into the
grove back in the year 2000
scarily enough having witnessed the
ceremony first hand
jones was convinced it wasn't an effigy
that was being burnt at all but an
actual living human child
sacrificed by these
men who rule the world as part of some
disturbing occultist ritual
once the cremation of care is out of the
way and everyone's worries have been
thoroughly incinerated
the camp truly begins
the location itself is stunning by the
way
nestled amongst towering california
redwoods the world's largest trees
bohemian grove is big enough to house
several thousand club members
simultaneously
there's an open-air dining circle that
can seat
1500 people and as for sleeping
arrangements there are a dozen or so
smaller camps spread across the site
each with its own distinct reputation
and famous patrons
george bush senior walter cronkite and
nasa astronaut frank bormann are known
to have favored a camp known as
hillbillies and herbert hoover was a
longtime occupant of caveman make of
that what he will
this picture from 1967 was taken at
breakfast in a camp called owl's nest
one of the most prestigious
harvey hancock is the one in the middle
he was eisenhower's campaign manager
during the 1952 american election the
guy sitting on either side ronald reagan
and richard nixon oil magnate edwin
paulie and nobel prize winning chemist
glenn seborg are also present
so how do these masters of the universe
spend their two-week sojourn in the
forest aside from burning children alive
obviously well there are daily lakeside
talks given by important club members
and regular entertainment in the form of
high and low jinx which are basically
just performances of various kinds
usually comedy or music
but what bohemian grove is really all
about is getting hammered then urinating
both frequently and aggressively the
first drink of the day a gin fizz is
served in bed by camp staff and the
alcohol keeps on flowing until long
after the sun's gone down unsurprisingly
considering bohemian club members are
almost exclusively gentlemen of advanced
years with prostates the size of
medicine balls there's a lot of visits
to the little boy's room or at least i
would be if there actually was a little
boy's room bohemian club members urinate
exclusively in the great outdoors a
privilege so important to them they've
even fought to defend it in court i'll
get to that in a minute with so many
influential people rubbing shoulders
you're probably assuming that plenty of
important business deals and world
altering policy decisions are made at
the camp every year but the club is
strict when it comes to talking business
its motto is weaving spiders come not
here
a line from shakespeare's a midsummer
night's dream that warns that bohemian
grove isn't supposed to be used as an
opportunity to network or do business
deals but like basically all mottos ever
this one is widely ignored plenty of
people go to bohemian grove with an
agenda and whilst most of the
earth-shuttering decisions that have
been made during
boozy nights amongst the redwoods are
remembered only by those involved a few
have become public knowledge
for example rumor has it that an early
planning meeting for manhattan project
including the likes of robert
oppenheimer and nobel prize winning
physicist ernest lawrence took place
during the 1942 iteration
of bohemian grove
directly leading to the invention of the
atomic bomb
earth-shattering indeed
by the way if all this important people
get together to do weird stuff in the
woods business is sounding kind of
familiar it may be that you're a house
of cards fan in series 5 of the netflix
show frank underwood played by kevin
spacey goes on an outdoor retreat with a
fictional secret society known as
elysian fields which draws heavily on
bohemian grove the episode opens with a
parody of the cremation of care ceremony
complete with a giant talking crow
statue and the burning of a human effigy
elysian fields has a motto too
buzzing bees do not sting here it's a
minor miracle the bohemian club didn't
sue
considering the guest list you won't be
surprised to learn that security at the
grove is taken very seriously the
redwood enclave is watched over by what
can best be described as a small private
army kitted out with high-tech gear
including thermal cameras
night vision goggles and both motion and
vibration sensing alarms the us secret
service has also been known to lend a
hand from time to time when the guest
list demands it
i should probably mention that bohemian
grove and the bohemian club in general
has come in from its fair share of
criticism over the years mostly due to
what some people see as sexist policies
no woman has ever been a full member in
the club's 150 year history and female
staff aren't employed at bohemian grove
in any capacity unless you believe the
rumor that the club's prepared to relax
its gender policies when it comes to
prostitutes when the club was first
formally charged with discrimination in
they fought back arguing that their
members wouldn't be able to urinate as
openly and liberally as they wanted to
if women were present at bohemian grove
the court ruled in their favor that
decision was eventually overturned but
the bohemian club did the litigatory
equivalent of asking to see the judge's
manager by filing an appeal with the
california superior court
at the subsequent trial they argued that
being male should be considered an
occupational qualification and since
most women struggle mastering the skill
of having a penis
they simply aren't qualified to work at
the grove the court once again ruled in
the club's favor the world's changed
quite a bit in the last 40 years hasn't
it oh i should probably mention that the
california superior court judge who
reached this
somewhat controversial decision
was known to have attended bohemian club
events on several occasions but i'm sure
that had absolutely nothing to do with
this decision whatsoever bohemian grove
ends every year as it began with an
elaborate performance
though thankfully no children real or
otherwise are burned in this one instead
a majestic redwood rimmed arena with
seating for up to 2 000 people
roughly the same capacity as london's
royal opera house hosts an end of camp
performance known as the grove play
written and performed exclusively by
grove club members and supported by a
full orchestra and production team it's
reported that grove plays which are only
ever performed a single time can cost
upwards of a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to stage
oh and since no women are allowed to
become members of the club any female
characters are played by men in drag
the oxford english dictionary defines a
bohemian as an artist literary man or
actor who leads a free vagabond or a
regular life and i don't know about you
but george bush senior isn't the first
person that springs to mind when i hear
the word vagabond i'm not the only one
who's picked up on this little
contradiction either when oscar wilde
visited the bohemian club in 1882 he was
heard commenting that he'd never seen so
many well-dressed well-fed
business-looking bohemians in all his
life
despite the somewhat optimistic branding
there's no doubt the bohemian club and
its two-week urination orgy in
california
will continue to capture the public's
imagination for as long as it exists
there's just something inherently
intriguing
about so many important people gathering
under such unusual circumstances to do
all these bizarre things
we
normals have always been interested in
how the other half lives
although i think it's safe to say that
up until now most of us assumed it was
more
leader jets and mansions than ritual
burnings and drag
so is bohemian grove a place where a
bunch of old white guys in various
states of midlife crisis go to recapture
their lost college days
or the hub of an illuminati-like
organization with a punch hunt for
burning babies i'll leave that up to you
oh and one last conspiracy theory for
you before i go
this is the u.s capitol building seen
from above
notice anything strange it looks a bit
like an owl right some people believe
that's a quiet nod to the bohemian club
right in the heart of washington dc
and intriguingly enough the current
design for the grounds was drawn up in
1874.
two years after the bohemian club was
founded of course back then the club was
literally no more than a bunch of
journalists with no power whatsoever but
hey why let the truth get in the way of
a good conspiracy
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in thank you